وممارسات النظام الايراني جعلته عرضه
للسيل من العقوبات سواء من الاتحاد
الاوروبي او من الولايات المتحده او من
غيرهما عقوبات لم تكن مرتبطه فقط
بالاحتجاجات بل ايضا بملفات اخرى من بينها
حبس واعدام مواطنين اجانب فضلا عن تهمه
تزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيره لاستخدامها ضد
اوكرانيا التهديد الاخير الذي يواجه
النظام الايراني هو امكانيه تصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه من طرف الاتحاد
الاوروبي
البرلمان الاوروبي فتح الباب امام المقترح
من خلال التصويت بالاجماع على دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لادراج الحرس الثوري ضمن
القائمه السوداء للمنظمات الارهابيه
والاثنين سيكون حاسما بخصوص هذا المقترح
حيث يعقد يعقد اجتماع لوزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك في حاله فرض او
لمناقشه فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده على ايران
وتعد دعوه البرلمان الاوروبيه هذه غير
ملزمه للاتحاد الاوروبي علما ان نص
المقترح يدعو الى حظر اي نشاط اقتصادي او
مالي مع الحرس من خلال شركات او مؤسسات قد
تكون مرتبطه به ويبقى المجلس الاوروبي
الوحيد المخول بنت خالي مثل هذه القرارات
او فرض عقوبه
سنعود الى خبر الشرطه الامريكيه بعد ان
ننهي ملف ايران التحركات الاوروبيه لادراج
الحرس الثوري في قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
اثارت موجه غضب في طهران التي لوحت بورقه
المعامله بالمثل بهذا الخصوص كتب وزير
الخارجيه الايراني امير عبد الحيان على
تويتر ان مجلس الشورى الايراني يعتزم وضع
اطراف من جيوش الدول الاوروبيه على قائمه
الارهاب وشدد عبد الله هيان على ان الرد
سيكون بالمثل مشيرا الى ان البرلمان
الاوروبي اطلق النار على نفسه بالتصويت ضد
الحرس الثوري وفي رد فعل الايراني اخر على
هذا المقترح حذر رئيس مجلس الشورى
الايراني محمد باقر قريبا باف من انه في
حاله اتخاذ اي اجراءات ضد الحرس الثوري
الايراني فاننا سنعتبر جيوش الدول
الاوروبيه جماعه ارهابيه